welcome back to the
third lecture of cs229 so in the first
two lectures we've been mostly going
over
the course prerequisites linear algebra
probability
so on wednesday's lecture just to recap
we went over the concept of determinant
it's geometrical interpretation
and we went through two different kinds
of decomposition of a matrix the eigen
value decomposition and the singular
value decomposition
after that we we quickly went through
some
matrix calculus the different ways in
which linear algebra
plays a role in calculus when we are
dealing with
multivariate functions and after that we
switched gears into
probability to review some basics of
probability theory
today we will finish up the review of
probability theory and
maybe in a few you know just spend a
couple of minutes on
on some basics of statistics of why
statistics plays a role
in machine learning and after that
we will jump right into our first
learning algorithm
uh linear regression that's the plan for
today
any questions about what we've covered
so far before we get started
okay so um we were reviewing probability
um and maybe let me just
go back a few slides to just touch upon
a few
um
concepts right so we covered um
what's a sample space sample space are
samples are basically the collection of
outcomes of
random experiments and events are
subsets of the sample space um
we assign probabilities to
events not to random outcomes but to
sets of random the sets of outcomes
and those are the axioms of probability
we went over what is uh the meaning of
independence with respect to
events um
an event is independent of the other if
the probability of their intersection
is the pro that is the product of their
individual probabilities
and then we um discuss this concept of a
random variable a random variable is
something that maps the the space of
outcomes which could be anything it
could be a string of heads and tails it
could be the color of a die it could be
anything whatsoever and we map it on to
the real line
and that's when we can start doing
mathematics with with
with randomness you know the concept of
a random variable maps
outcomes which could be in in any sample
space
on to the real line right
for example we could have a random
variable that
counts the number of heads on in a given
event ah
and to map it map that ah event
outcome let me say that again so here we
have an example of a random variable
which uh takes as input um the outcome
the outcome in this case is a string of
10 heads or tail coin flips and that is
just a string of you know
heads or tail symbols it's not a number
and a random variable an example of a
random variable in this case
is a random variable that just counts
the number of
heads in in in that sequence of 10
ah coin flips and maps it to a real
number
right and
ah by by values of x we means the set of
all possible
real values that the random variable can
possibly map
any of the outcomes into
and then we spoke about the cumulative
distribution function
so previously we saw that a probability
measure is defined on
events but once we map it to the real
line once we convert
define a random variable the probabil
the probability measure kind of induces
some kind of
a probability measure on the real line
right and
that can be captured by uh something
called as the cumulative distribution
function
it is basically the measure or the the
um
the probability assigned to the set of
all
outcomes which get mapped to
a value less than or equal to the uh the
desired threshold
right so this is how
a cdf would you know look for a
continuous random variable
so the the height of this function
is measuring the amount of uh
probability
assigned to the set of all events
the set of all ah the set of all
outcomes that mapped less than or equal
to the
the uh desired threshold so that's what
what we have here
so it is the p over here is now
measuring
an event a set of outcomes and the set
of outcomes is defined as the pre image
of the random variable right the random
variable maps outcomes to to the real
line and
if you look at the pre image of that
function that is the set of all inputs
that get mapped
uh to a value less than uh or equal to
the
the uh desired threshold that will give
you a probability and that's going to be
a value between 0 and 1
and which is why this this
the values of the cdf lie between zero
and one
right and we spoke about discrete versus
continuous variables
discrete variables have a probability
mass function and continuous variables
have a probability density function
right
a cdf or a cumulative uh distribution
function
exists for all random variables um that
is the the cdf that we
um so over here this a cdf exists for
all random variables whether it's
discrete or continuous
but the density function
exists only for continuous distribution
which is basically the derivative of
the cdf
it's important to note that the density
of
the the value returned by the density
function is not the probability
what i mean by that is if
suppose this is x and we have some
density function
and suppose this is 0.3
right and this has some height
right it is important to to note that
the probability of x equals 0.3
is not equal to this height
right the probability for any continuous
random variable
uh the probability that the the random
variable
takes a specific value is always zero
that's
that sounds that may sound a little
counter-intuitive if you're
if you're uh hearing this for the first
time but you know
let me say that again if we have a
discrete probability
a discrete random variable with a
probability mass function
like 1 2 3 then the probability that the
random variable takes on the value 3
is given by the height of the
probability mass function but
the probability density function is
something that's fundamentally
different in the sense the height of the
of of the density measure at that point
is not the probability
that the random variable takes on the
value of for example
0.3 right probabilities in case of
continuous random variables
are only defined on intervals or sets of
intervals
so the area under the probability
density function
for a given ah range of your
input the area under the probability
density function
is the probability that the random
variable takes a value
in this range right but the probability
that a continuous random variable
takes any specific value is always zero
right so that's that's uh that's yes
questions
well so the the question is um
if i understand you correctly let me
rephrase it and then you can tell me if
i
understood your question correctly is uh
we don't
know where the what value the continuous
random variable is going to take so how
can you define
[Music]
the probability to be 0 well so this is
you know
you can think of probability as the the
so there are two two kind of um
interpretations to probabilities one is
um looking historically what's been like
the distribution of
of uh you know the your true random
variable uh taking on in the past and
then based on that you can
probably construct some kind of a
density or estimate some kind of a
density
what it actually means is just because
if you take a continuous random variable
the number of possible values it can
take is
uncountably infinite and that
makes it uh impossible or a continuous
random variable is
is uh does not have point masses in the
sense
uh any given value in this among this
infinite uncountably infinite number of
uh
possible values any any um
any given value of of these has zero
probability of occurrence
but if you take a range you get a
probability for
the value falling in that range
right okay so that's uh discrete versus
continuous probability
and and then we we we started talking
about this very important concept called
expectation right expectation is
um expectation is uh
a concept that's only associated with a
random variable
right so uh we spoke about
outcomes and we spoke about
events right and we define
a probability measure on events
so if we limit ourselves to just these
concepts then the concept of expectation
does not come into picture yes question
lights
is okay okay ah can you see the slides
as well is it too bright for the slides
right okay okay so um if we are only
limiting ourselves to the concepts of
outcomes and events then there is no
such thing as an expectation
but once we define a random variable
right a random variable
as we saw last time was it
i'm going to draw the outcome space as
or the sample space with a squiggly line
just because it's it's it's not like a
linearly ordered line
and then we define a random variable so
assume this is
some random variable x that maps
outcomes to the real line right you
could have
another random variable which maps
the same sample space to the real line
in a different way let's call this
y of omega now only after we
define this concept called a random
variable the concept of expectation
comes into picture
so expectation is
what is the well an informal way to
think about expectation is
what value does this random variable
take on average
right that's that's um so we have a
function
right that maps um
outcomes to the real line and um
generally we we kind of flip this axis
over and we we
we start with the vertical line uh
flipped over
and we ask ourselves
suppose we ah there is a function g
defined on top of this random variable
so let this be some function g
of x
and this is x and
the values over here are those values
are
are coming from random out
coming from outcomes that got mapped on
to the real line and then
the expectation is now asking what is
the average value
that g g will return right and the
average value that g returns
is going to depend on the way on
depend on what values we are feeding
into x
right and what what expectation
informally is if we feed values into g
according to the distribution that is
induced by x
right so events happen you sample events
right map it to x through the random
variable feed that
that value of x into g and you get some
value right
so suppose this this this
outcome happened map it to x right x
maps it to g and this is the value of g
right
and similarly ah you repeat this
experiment over and over
right different outcomes map you to
different values of x and different
values of x
map due to different values of g of x
and
you're measuring what you know the
various values of g
and you're trying to ask the question
what's the average value of g
in general what right and you can ask
the question of average value
only because now you have things on the
real line
right on the sample space there's no
such thing as an average
there's no such thing as an average
sample because you know
you have a die with six colors what's
the average color you know it's it's not
a meaningful once you map them to
numbers you can ask what's
what's the what's the average value
right and for a discrete random variable
the
expectation is ah is defined like this
right sum over all the possible values x
can take
and for for for each of those values
multiply g of x that is the value g of x
returns times the probability x takes
that value
right and this is just a weighted sum of
the different values of g of x according
to the probability
with which x can occur right very
intuitive definition of
expectation and similarly the uh
for continuous random variables um it's
defined like this
in place of the the summation we have an
integral
right now you're integrating over all
possible values of x
right and for each value of x we measure
the
density right not the probability but
the density
and because we are not using densities
we you know have an integral instead of
a sum
right this question
x so what the question is g of x so x is
a random variable
and g of x is some function of x
it's just some function of x right it's
g is defined here g
is some some function that takes a real
value as input and outputs a real value
right and you can if you know g is just
a function you
you know um in this case the input of x
in input to g is going to be the random
variable which means you know
it can take on different values
according to the
outcome of some random random experiment
right so that's the expectation of g of
x and
we saw um
an important concept last
in the last lecture that you can
approximate
g of x by taking random samples
of x and calculating the average of g of
x for that sample right and that is
called the
monte carlo estimate of the expectation
and as the
number of samples tends to infinity
right as you as you estimate the
expectation with more and more number of
samples
the the monte carlo estimate converges
to
the true true expectation right and that
is basically the law of large numbers
right any questions about that
right so that was still ah that that's
that's uh what we covered
um on wednesday and today we're going to
continue
further now we're going to talk about
variance
so what's the variance of x variance of
x
is defined as is there a question
so the variance of x is is defined as
the expectation of
x minus expectation of x square now what
is what is happening here
it basically means suppose
x has some distribution for example
let's suppose
this is the probability density of of
ah of x right
the expectation is also um
the point that's kind of um
the point that's you can you can you can
think of it as kind of the
um if you imagine this probability
density function
to have some kind of a shape then the
expectation
is that point on x which which is
basically like the center of gravity
like right if you
if you if you take an actual physical
thing of of this shape
and you try to balance it on the on the
expectation then you know your your
that shape will kind of stay balanced
right it's like the center of gravity
right that's that's the intuition for
expectation
um the the variance is kind of trying to
measure
how spread apart is this random variable
around its around its mean so this is
going to be
the expectation um
the the variance is trying to measure
how spread apart
is this uh distribution in general right
uh there's also um another concept
called the median of the distribution
so the median of the distribution is
supposing this is the median
the median of the distribution is uh
the point that divides the mass into
into into uh equal masses on either side
right and for symmetric distribution the
median and the expectation are
are the same right however um
there could be distributions which are
which are you know
for example you have a distribution like
this
right in this case the median could be
somewhere over here
but the expectation could be so this
could be the median and this could be
the expectation
because the the point where you balance
a mass is not necessarily the point
where
you know you have equal masses on both
sides because you know um
i think i think that's called the moment
of inertia or something like that where
if you have a mass that's the kind of
spread
all the way on the other side then that
has more effect so if you want to
balance things
that's the point where that's that's the
mean or the expectation and median is
the thing that
divides it into equal masses on both
sides right and the variances is trying
to measure
how spread apart is this if you could
have a distribution that has
a given expectation and a small variance
or you could have a distribution that
has a given expectation and a large
variance
right
these are two different expressions for
uh
for for uh the variance of of x and
they're
uh both equivalent that's showing this
is pretty simple it's in the notes
and here are some examples of various uh
distributions
and their parameters right parameters
now this is the first time
we're talking about parameters what's a
parameter
right so when we're talking about
distributions there are kind of two
concepts
one is the the space over which the
distribution is being defined supposing
it's a random variable it is you know um
the real line
on on which the the distribution is
being defined
and then you have a parameter a
parameter is
basically a number that tries to
summarize the shape of the distribution
right for example um if you have a
gaussian random variable which is
also called the normal distribution or
the bell curve
it has two
two parameters so one is
the ah so this is the real line
and this is the gaussian pdf
and mu is the the mean of the gaussian
distribution
and sigma is like it's called a standard
deviation
right so a gaussian distribution is
is summarized by mu and
the variance sigma square where sigma is
the standard deviation
similarly there are you know many
different
distributions and each of them have have
um you know parameters
some distributions have just one
parameter some have two some have three
ah but most of the distributions we're
going to be interested in
in this course are are you know going to
have one or two parameters
right you can have
you can look at two random variables
jointly
right and for that um what that means is
supposing you have a variable x and a
variable y
together they have a joint cdf which
means
the probability that x the variable x
is less than the x threshold and the
probability that y is less than the y
threshold right so you think of the
comma over here as
as as the logical and right
similarly you have a bivariate
probability mass function which is you
know the probability that
x in this case x and y are discrete in
in the continuous they were here they
were continuous
so this is the probability that
x takes the value you know small x and
the random variable y takes the value
small y given two
given the joint p a pdf
of two random variables you can
construct their marginals right
so if you have two random variables
let's call it x and y
the the uh
the distribution that that that uh
captures
the most information of these two is the
joint distribution of the two
and that will have assuming they are
continuous you know
you write it as p of x comma y
right that's the the
joint distribution of the two similarly
you can have the
marginal distributions of the two random
variables
and the marginal distributions is going
to be
written as p of x or p of y
and the way you get these is to what's
what's
called as marginalizing out or summing
out or integrating out
the other variables so sum of all the y
p of x comma y and you get this or
similarly if it's
a continuous random variable then you
integrate out p
of x comma y d y
right and and this is just the other way
so here you sum out x
if it is discrete
so this is discrete and this is
continuous
and here it will be summing over
right now the ah
the way to think about the the joint
pdf is that the
the joint pdf or the joint pmf has to
satisfy the property
right so in if you integrate out both
the variables
the the joint pdf has to integrate to
one
right and if you integrate out only one
variable
then you get a distribution with respect
to the other variable
and that is called the marginal
distribution
right so ah given given these concepts
of
the joint and the marginal we can define
the bayes theorem the base theorem is
probably one of the
the most important theorems in in
probability theory it's going to show up
all over the place especially in this
course and even beyond
and the base theorem basically gives you
uh the relation between
the conditional distribution the joint
distribution and the marginal
distribution
right so the
base the base theorem
looks like this so p of
x comma y you can write this as
p of x times
p of y given x right so this
is the joint
this is the marginal
and this is the conditional probability
right so the way you want to remember
this is the joint
is the product of the marginal and the
conditional right but you can also write
this as
p of y times p of x given y
right and the way you decompose the
joint into
into these two parts is called the chain
rule right so there's a chain rule in
calculus this is the chain rule of
probability theory
right so the chain rule tells you that
you can you can always for
any pair of random variables you can
decompose the joint
into the marginal times the conditional
right and a trivial consequence of this
chain rule is the base theorem so the
base theorem
basically equates these two so you write
p of
x times p of y given x
equals p of y times
p of x given y right
and assuming p of x is
never zero you can divide both sides by
p
of x and that gives you p of y given x
equals p of y times p of
x given y over p of x
right so this is
base theorem right it's it's it's a very
simple consequence of
of the uh of the chain rule you apply
the chain rule in two different ways
equate the two different ways and divide
uh divide over by one of the modules and
you get the base rule
yeah so here we are writing this in
terms of x f but you know um
you can you can use f or p uh doesn't
matter
and another way um in which base the
base theorem is is also commonly written
is
retain the numerator as it is p of y
times p of
x given y and
ah the the denominator is
instead of writing it as p of x you're
going to write it as assuming its its a
discrete
sum over y prime
p of y prime times
p of x given y prime
these two are the same why are they the
same because
p of y prime times p of x given y prime
is the joint
right it's the joint and you're
marginally
marginalizing out y prime from this
which gives you p of x
right maybe you know just just to add
this is basically
equal to summing over y prime of
p of x comma y prime
right you're going to use this form of
the bayes theorem also in this course
right any questions
so some of you sitting over here you may
not be able to see this
uh read this because this kind of comes
in the way so maybe you can
go over next time or you can move over
even now if you want to
all right example of base rule let's
skip over this
independence so the independence of two
random variables is very similar
to uh independence of of
two events they are distinct concepts
independence
uh we we spoke about independence of
random events a few slides ago here we
are talking about independence of two
random variables
and the independence of two random
variables is defined like this that the
uh the joint probability
is equal to the product of the marginal
probabilities right or the joint density
densities
uh that also you know um that's
basically telling you know if it is
independent right you are saying p of
this is equal to p of x times p of y so
if if two
random variables are independent then
you know you
p of y must be equal to p of y given x
right we saw
something very similar for random for
independence of random events
it's uh it's it's very very uh
very similar so p of y given uh x of two
variables will be equal to uh p of y yes
question
so the question is if two random
variables are independent can we say
that the
uh events that they are um
defined or are also independent
right
it it must be the case right yeah
next question yes question
go back a slide
this is defined when f of x is not equal
so the um when when uh the probability
uh so assuming we are talking about
discrete
um uh in the discrete case
the uh conditional of y given x itself
is not defined if the probability of x
is zero
right assuming that the conditional is
defined you know
the def uh the base theorem tells you
that you know you can represent it like
this
does that make sense so so the
conditional probability itself is
defined only when
ah you know conditional of y of x is
defined only when x has a non-zero
probability
so um over here this is the
conditional distribution of y given
x takes on some you know a given value
right
right next we are going to talk about
this ah you know uh so
yeah independence so we're gonna you
know independent random variables
are are um are super important because
it lets you decompose the joint
probability into just
product of the marginals and this
independence makes um this independence
is what makes a lot of machine learning
theory kind of you know
easy to to work with we
we make we are going to be making um
assumptions about you know your training
examples
um which you think of them as random
variables being independent of each
other
so the concept of independence is uh
is is very important let's skip over
this
right this is the expectation of two
random variables uh
you can go over these in your slides um
just like the concept of um
of variance there is the concept of
covariance when we are talking about
two random variables right uh and the
covariance
um of of uh random variables are defined
like this
so so the variance of
so the variance of
x was defined as expectation
of x square minus
expectation of x
squared we saw this on a few slides ago
similarly
the covariance of x comma y
is defined as expectation of
x r times y
minus expectation of x
into expectation of y
which basically tells you that the
covariance
of x with x is just the variance of x
all right the multivariate gaussian so
this
is one of the most commonly used
distributions defined over
a collection of random variables right
and
this is something that's going to show
up a whole lot in this course
and hopefully towards the end of the
course
if you're woken up in the middle of your
sleep and ask you what's the probability
density of a multivariate gaussian
you'll be able to say this you know
instinctively
right this looks looks a little
scary at first but let's let's um let's
kind of
dissect it a little bit so
so x is in some n
dimensional uh space
and the probability ah the density of
x given two parameters mu
and sigma is defined as
1 over 2 pi
to the n by 2
times the determinant of sigma to the
power
half times the exponent
of minus half
x minus mu transpose
sigma inverse x minus mu
wow so um
first of all let's see what's happening
here
and add some color to it so x is
the space over which we are
defining the the probability density
so we see that x appears only here
inside the exponent
right and you have two parameters mu and
and and sigma the sigma is called the
covariance matrix
and mu is the is the is the mean
and the covariance matrix
shows up over here so let's
reverse and then we have the mean and
the mean
maybe i'll use black for this
mean all right
so uh this is the is the um
um the joint
the the joint distribution of a
multivariate
gaussian and we right away recognize a
few things that we have seen in our
linear algebra course before
right so first of all uh sigma is a
matrix
right it's called a covariance matrix it
turns out to be
a positive semi-definite matrix
any covariance matrix for any any uh
joint distribution no matter what the
distribution is is always going to be
positive semi-definite
right so this and this is a positive
semi-different matrix
and we it is going to be full rank which
means the inverse will exist
right and we recognize a few more things
so this is the
is the determinant of the matrix
right that's the uh notation for uh the
determinant and it's it's like the
square root of the denominator
um and we also see this form of
over here does anybody recognize this
form
this is the quadratic form so x minus mu
is some vector
right and what we are doing is x minus
mu transpose some matrix times x minus
mu
right so this is the quadratic form that
we also spent some time on
right so all all the all the
review that we did with linear algebra
is going to apply on this
shortly right and this term over here
is just some constant it has no mean
no no data no covariance this is just
some constant
and the purpose of this 1 over 2 pi to
the n by 2
the purpose of its existence is to only
make this
the integral of this with respect to x
be equal to 1. so this this just some
normalizing constant
right yes question
exactly so the question is if this is a
multivariate distribution what does the
integral with respect to x mean
it it means exactly what you said you're
integrating out all x 1 through x
n
you hear me okay yeah okay sorry um so
um the the integral
would look something like this you would
have um
p of x
mu sigma square times dx1 dx2
right it would be a double integral or a
triple integral or
right so this is the the uh
the multivariate gaussian density and
we're going to be working a whole lot
with this so
you know you you'll get familiar with
this uh if you if you
uh if you're not already
and here are some intuitions about what
the mean and
covariance matrix of a multivariate
gaussian looks like
so what we have in the in the left
are examples of particular instances of
mu
and sigma the figure on the
center is a plot of the probability
density function um here it's it's a
two-dimensional gaussian
and the the figure on the rightmost
column
is what's also called a contour plot or
a heat map
where a lighter color a color of orange
means
that that region has a higher value and
blue means it has a low value
so imagine um looking at
the the plot in the middle directly from
the top
and using different colors to represent
different heights
right that's that's the uh plot on the
right
right so uh let's just get a feel for
you know what the different
different parameters mean in terms of
the probability density
so a mu equal to 0 means
the center of the distribution or or
the the distribution is going to be
centered around 0 0
right we see this to be the you know 0 0
over here and
the the peak of the distribution is over
zero zero in this case
and the the covariance matrix
the diagonals of the covariance matrix
are the
variances of the marginals of x one and
x two
right so it it what what this roughly
means is that
x the variable x1 so if you if you just
look at
x1 over here it's going to have like a
standard deviation of one
you know it it that looks roughly
correct um
if you if you imagine this to be the x
direction it has like a
a standard deviation of 1 and x 2 also
has
a standard deviation of 1. and the cross
entries in the covariance matrix are the
actual
covariances between those two random
variables a covariance of 0
here roughly means that there is no
strong relation between x1 and x2 which
makes it takes
a spherical shape
moving on so here's another example
where
the the covariance matrix has
smaller diagonal elements which means
the distribution is
still centered around zero but it is
more concentrated it has a smaller
variance
right which means it is more peaked
okay it is more peak compared to
this distribution and in terms of the
contour plot
the the the circles just appear to be
smaller right
and similarly if you increase the
variance
of um of your distribution
the covariances are still zero which
means it is still spherically shaped
right ah now it it it looks more
flattened
right your probability density looks
more flatter and the
concentric circles are also more
expanded
right let's look at a few more examples
now um over here you know this is still
the the uh
the first picture now now let us
scale the x1 to have uh variance point
six
and x2 to have variance one so x1
is now more um
compressed but x2 still maintains the
same variance so you see from the
contour plot over here
um that it it is more
vertically aligned probably the slides
the shape the projection of the slides
make it look a little different but
that's that's the um it seems on the on
on the picture over there this looks
like a circle but it's supposed to be
you know compressed vertically and it's
it's uh supposed to be longer
now instead of shrinking x one if we
expand x one
right now you see that it it stretch
across more widely
right but still there is no correlation
between um
between x1 and x2 so you don't see
any particular you know correlation over
there
now let's add some correlation right now
um
x1 and in this case
x1 and x2 still have a variance of 1
and 1 but now we've added a correlation
of 0.5 which means
as you increase x1 x2 also tends to
increase that's that's the
general idea that x1 and x2 tend to
co-occur
you know more you know as you increase
the values of x
if you increase the covariance further
you know the
the relation becomes even tighter even
stronger
right uh the marginals in this case are
still
one and one which means from uh if
if you if you were to
integrate out x1 you would get a
probability density of
of a unit of mean zero uh variance one
on on x2 and similarly if you were to
integrate out x2 you would still get you
know a normal curve on
on the x1 axis
right so that this some you know
intuition for
how a multivariate gaussian ah would
would look you know with with two
dimension it's easy to to uh
visualize and get some intuitions
right so um if the this is the next
slide and uh if the correlation is
negative
now what what this means is larger
values of x
x1 tend to co-occur with smaller values
of x2
right so
for example over here for x x1 equal to
you know
for x1 to have a particular color you
know
um x2 has to be you know negative
uh that's what it means so you so you
see a reverse relation
between um x1 going up and x2 uh going
down and if you again
make it negative and make it a bigger
number you see a stronger
correlation between x1 and x2 but in the
in the in the reverse direction
similarly ah for a given covariance
matrix you can uh
move your you know use a different mu
which means
uh the covariance matrix is deciding the
shape
and orientation of the of the um
of this function and mu tells you where
to place it
where to center it right so this is
basically the same
bell shaped but placed at x 1 equal to 0
and x 2 equals 0.5 so here you see it's
just
in terms of x2 it's moved up a little
bit
right and and uh this this is another
example where x1 is 1.5 the
the center of the distribution is at x 1
equals 1.5 and x 2 equals minus 0.5
that's where the center is and the
covariance matrix decides the shape and
orientation
right any questions yes questions
so if you if you uh the question is this
is with respect to
two variables and what do we have more
variables is that the question
yeah so if you have a three-dimensional
gaussian
then you would have a three by three
covariance matrix and
each of the pairwise correlations will
be
the values in the corresponding cell
right ok so
conditional probability uh
[Music]
we went over this already
so here's a useful uh identity which is
the conditional expectation
right so the conditional expectation is
another important concept in in
probability and the conditional
expectation
is uh defined like this
and the conditional expectation is
actually is actually somewhat subtle
right
so conditional expectation
is
so the conditional expectation of
e of x given
y so you think of the conditional
expectation in this form where x and y
are random variables
to be a random variable
right the expectation of x
is a constant
right but the conditional variable of
expectation the continuous expression of
x given y
is another random variable right
x is random x is random y is random
expectation of x is just a constant it
is not random
right conditional expectation of x given
y
is a random variable right it's a random
variable defined over the space of y
however conditional
expectation of x given y equals
small y this is
a function
of small y
right the conditional expectation of x
given y where you're you know
you're just placing the random variable
over here is another random variable
right it doesn't look like it but x
given y
kernel expectation of x equal y is
another random variable
but the conditional expectation of x
given y equals
some specific y is a function of
that's specific why yes question
these two are not the same in the sense
this is still a random variable this
whole thing is
random variable and this whole thing is
a function of small y
this is this is a subtle concept and
you may want to go back to your
probability book to kind of
go through this again but this can be
this can be relevant in some of your
homework
so that you know you want you want to
have a good
good good clear understanding of that
or view these as distinct things
conditional expectation of x given y
where y is still random variable is
another random variable
it is basically you're saying you're
feeding
a random variable y as input and this
becomes a function of y and therefore
it's still a random variable can think
of it that way
yes questions
exactly so the question is if this is a
random variable then can we apply
all the all the rules that we've seen so
far on this you
exactly you can but you cannot on this
one
yes
so over here the random variable is
defined over the space of
y only
yes question
random variables are functions already
this is a function of y of of
uh you know over small y but you know
this is a random variable in the sense
this is a function over your sample
space
think of it that way
this is just uh over the sample space of
y alone
so maybe the next next slide might make
it a little more clear
uh so so maybe you know hold your
question until the end of the next slide
uh and there was a one more question yes
questions
yeah so in the case of gaussian you can
think of it like this right so
assume this is the contour plot of of
gaussians where it is
centered on some let's call this say
plus one and plus two and the
expectation and let's call this
x and let us call this y so
the expectation of of
x given y equals you know
say some small value y
and assume the small value y is this
right uh
what it basically tells us if you kind
of
limit yourself with this slice of of the
gaussian
and that's going to be you know just
going to have some kind of a bell shape
and what's the expectation of it
yes question
so this is a function of small y
expectation of
that's a typo that should be small y
sorry
yeah this over here should be small y
thank you
yeah so um
so now we have something called the law
of total expectation
right so the law of total expectation
tells us that
expectation of x
can be written as the expectation
of expectation of x given y
right now this holds true
for any x and any y
right y could be completely independent
of x it could be
dependent on x but the expectation of x
can always be decomposed into this
nested form where
you condition on y you get a new random
variable
right and take the expectation of of
this random variable
and you get back the expectation of x
this is called the law of total
expectation
um and and um
while this holds true for any y in
general
you have the choice of choosing the y
and you want to choose a why that makes
your problem easier to solve by you know
breaking it down this way
right and and the choice of what why you
want to choose is more of an
art and you've got to uh when you're
asked to calculate you know the
expectation of x and it's it's you know
it's pretty
uh it's pretty complex uh you want to
use some
some creativity in choosing a y
to defining this random variable
and and then take the expectation of
that and by breaking it down into
like sub problems uh you can you can
solve some complex problems
so uh the expectation of x given y where
y is left unspecified is a random
variable
and that's what shows up here in the law
of total expectation
and when you take the expectation of
that you get back the expectation of x
itself
yes question
this one yeah you you you can think of
it as a function of big y
uh that's one way to think of it or just
think of this as a random variable
this is a random variable like z you
know think of this as z you know some
random variable
right here's a proof to show you know
this just proving a lot of total
expectation i'm not going to go over
this you can uh
go through this yourself pretty
straightforward there's nothing uh
complex going on here
and there's one more version of bayes
rule that's going to be
helpful for you
right so ah
so let us write the bayes rule that we
have already seen p of
a given b
is equal to p of b
given a times p
of a over
[Music]
p of b right so this is the bayes rule
that we saw already
right and the bayes rule basically also
allows you to
have another variable that is
conditioned throughout
right so you can think of just the
conditional base rule which means
p of
b comma c
right so you you can have c condition
in all the terms and this is also
bayes rule the the expression that you
uh see over here
right similarly you can also um so this
is the base rule where we are kind of
swapping
a and b over here similarly you could
have also just as well kept b
conditioned throughout and just swapped
a and c right and that's that's also
you can think of that as base rule
all right any more any questions
okay with this okay so here's a proof
for this you can go over this but you
know you can just
you can just remember it this way and
you can apply it you
you know this proof is just to convince
yourself you're not going to test you on
these kind of grooves
with that we finished the review of
probability
any questions now i want to take a few
moments to
to kind of give you a a slightly a big
picture overview of
the role statistics plays in machine
learning right
um
what we saw in the slide so far right we
had
parameters
right for example mu
sigma of the gaussian right and we had
observations
the parameters and we had ah
observations for example in the
multivariate gaussian you had x
in some r n
right so ah probability basically
is the field where
you are trying to make statements about
the observations
given your parameters right
probably t right so given given
parameters you are trying to
make statements about about the data you
know what is the probability of this
what's going to be the marginal
probability what's the conditional
probability
what's the joint probability things like
that
so given obs given given given
parameters
we assume that the parameters are given
or they are fixed and you are making
statements about
observations or our data you can think
of this as data
right and
statistics is kind of doing like the
opposite right you're given data you
start with data
and you're trying to make statements
about your parameters
right you make some assumptions and
statistics about what the
distribution is you know given given
uh given the data and you take the data
that's given to you
right you're not making statements about
you know what
the probability of some other data is uh
or anything like that but given the data
you're trying to make statements about
the parameters
right and and and that's statistics and
you're you're trying to uh
um generally the the statements that you
make about the parameters and statistics
are about
things like is this parameter value
equal to zero or
is this parameter value much farther
away from zero
right and you you're going to assign you
know p values for those
observations you're going to define
confidence intervals where you know what
what you believe
uh the the range for those parameters
are right so you start from
from data and make statements about the
parameters and statistics but in
probability you're kind of
you know going the other way and and
these two are kind of you know like
yin and yang they're kind of coupled to
each other
right and there are many many techniques
to
um estimate parameters um given
given your data right so
things like method of moments
or maximum likelihood estimation
and it is this approach that is kind of
relevant for us in this course and for
most of machine learning
and using these techniques
you you kind of feed an x as the input
for these techniques and it's going to
output some
some some parameters for you right
now where does machine learning come
into picture so with machine learning
what you're trying to do is you're given
what's called as a training data
right your training data is going to be
some collection of x
um you know you can think of them as x y
pairs for supervised learning
and you're given a collection of them
right and
given that given your training data you
want to
learn the parameters of your model
you're going to define some kind of a
model
for for this data and learn the
parameters and using the learnt
parameters
so for machine learning you know
you feed training data
right and you're going to learn your
model
and using those models you want to make
predictions about future data
right so machine learning we are
actually
the goal that we are interested in is
actually given the training data make
predictions about future data
right but incidentally we kind of
take statistical approaches where we
build a model and use the model to make
predictions on future data and that's
where kind of statistics comes into
picture where you know you're given
given training data use tools from
statistics like maximum likelihood
estimation and other things to
learn the model
even though we are using the same tools
of statistics the goals are very
different
in statistics the goal is to make
statements about the parameters itself
right in machine learning we really
don't care about the parameters at all
all we care is how good is this model in
making predictions about future data
and that's how we measure the quality of
machine learning
methods you know how good is it in
making predictions about
about future data whereas in statistics
you know the game ends here we measure
how good the model is or how good our
method is in terms of making
proper statements about the parameters
right in machine learning we
this is this is a black box for us right
we
it does estimate your parameters but
they are not of direct interest to us
they are only
we are only interested in the parameters
because they help us make predictions
about future data right
and this
this part of the cycle is also what is
called as
learning or training
or fitting with the model with data
right and in
in in classical statistics you also call
this statistical inference
right you are inferring what the
parameters are given
given the data and once you have data
this is called prediction
right you are making predictions about
about future data about
unseen things things that you haven't
seen before about data that you haven't
encountered before
right and which which brings us to
maximum likelihood estimation right in
maximum likelihood estimation
um
call it mle
now emily um
we let's start with a very simple
example of
mle to kind of give you the flavor of
let's let's start with gaussians
gaussian data so in the here we are
going to talk about a simple situation
where we are
given data x in rd
and you're given a collection of them
i'm going to write them as x
1 through
x n in this notation
what i mean is each x
i is the ith example
it does not mean x raised to the power
of i or x raised to the power of
n whenever i write the superscript with
parentheses
it means it's the ith example right
and there are n such examples
each example is in rd
so it is each each x i is a d
dimensional vector
right and we are given let us assume we
are given
n such examples right now
the probability we already saw the
probability density of
of of the gaussian which is p of x
given mu comma sigma
is equal to 1 over 2
pi to the d by 2
half exponent
right so this is the
probability
density right
now we are now going to define something
called as the likelihood function
right so let us define the likelihood
function
of the parameters mu
comma sigma given
given the data x right
and for notation let's let's call x
as the
as the collection of uh your n examples
and over here the semicolon means um
things to the right are kind of think of
them as parameters or think of them as
as you know given values and the
function is being defined on the
variables that are to the left of the uh
semi semicolon
right in order to define the likelihood
function
we are going to make yet another
assumption
the assumption here is that each of
these
are sampled
independently
and identically
distributed
right so this is also commonly called i
i
d
and this is going to be a very common
assumption in all
our in all machine learning methods that
the the training data that you have
are sampled in an iid fashion which
means
x 1 through x n are all independent of
each other they were sampled
independently
right now the like we defined the
likelihood function as
so um
so this was for one example let's make
this
um for all the examples
so the probability of x 1
through x n
mu comma sigma is going to be
we saw we we saw independence
that p of x 1
through x n if x 1 through x n
are independent of each other we can
write this as the product
of i equals 1 through n
p of x i
right this is this means product
you're you're you're multiplying the the
terms over here
right yes question
all right all right let me let me i i
haven't uh finished this yet so
let me come back to this in a moment
right so
the uh the joint probability of
independent
uh independent pieces of data is the
product of the individual marginals
right now if you want to define the
probability density of your full data
set
x 1 through
[Music]
x n mu
sigma you're going to write this as the
product
of i equals 1 through
n 1 over
2 pi to the d by 2
f exponent
minus half here x
i minus mu transpose
does this make sense because we are
making um think of this as
this was for the case of one example but
if you are given you know
an entire training set the probability
density of the full training set
because of the iid assumption we can
break it down into
the the probabilities of individual
examples and just uh
multiply over them yes question
x is a vector as a vector of d
dimensions yes
so this in this case x is also a vector
right so you have x minus mu transpose
you know this this is still in
in a vector setting
right so this is for one example
that the example is still vector valued
and this is
um n examples where each of the example
is still
d dimensional yes question
so the semicolon is a way of saying
things that come to the right
you're treating them as given
you don't think of them as variables
they're just some some some constants
right now um so this is the probability
density
and it is precisely this iid assumption
that lets us break down a complex
problem
into smaller pieces right its
representing this as one large gaussian
would have would
just makes it a harder problem we don't
even know um
you know what this distribution might
look like if there is you know
if the interactions are pretty complex
so instead
when we make the iid assumption that
your training data just came to you
each example was was generated
independently we break it down into
um you know smaller problems now
once we have this ah you know
this as the probability density you're
going to now define the likelihood
function
so the likelihood function is
you know in in the spirit of this a
probability density function
takes x as your data x as the
your data is the variable and assumes
your parameters to be given
but for going the other way we're going
to take your data to be
you know given and your parameters are
the thing you want to
make a statement over so over here the
likelihood function
is going to be over mu and sigma
x x one through
x n right
and you know ah to no surprise
this is going to look
exactly like this
next question
yeah hold that question for a moment
here um
what we see is that this expression over
here in case of the gaussian
this the the the uh what we thought of
as the density function
also you we can repurpose it as our
likelihood function
the difference is that in case of when
we when we think of this as
a density function right the
the data is kind of the function is
defined over the data space
right but when we define it as a
likelihood function
ah product from i equals
1 to n 1 over 2 pi
to the d by 2
sigma to the half
exponent of f
x i
minus mu inverse
x i minus
right it is basically the same
expression
but we are interpreting it differently
we consider
in the likely when we see this as a
likelihood function we think of
the vari the parameters to be the
variables
right and your data to be given right
when we think of reinterpret this as the
probability density function
we think of the data as the variables
and your parameters to be fixed
yes question
right so the question is when you think
when you write probability of mu comma
sigma given x
so so a small correction over there when
we
we use the term
probability
of data
right we never use the term probability
of your
parameters and we use the term
likelihood of your parameters
right the the correct phrases to use is
probability of the data
given parameters
and the likelihood of the parameters
given data
right that is that is the
only difference in terms of uh you know
mathematically
but semantically we are treating the the
um the data as as the variable here but
the parameters as variable here other
other than that
the expression is just the same and
the one of the obvious another obvious
way in which they are different
is if if you integrate your probability
density over its variables
you get one right but if you integrate
your likelihood with respect to you know
for your
parameter space it may not even exist
yes questions
does the likelihood form one particular
slice in the in the
that that's a good question so let's
let's kind of
go over that again
so assume this is your probability
density function right
now the shape of this curve and the
position and you know everything about
this curve
is kind of fixed by the mu and sigma
right and the x axis is data or
observation
right now the likelihood
for this is going to be
mu sigma and this is
likelihood and here it was the
probability density and
the likelihood function is going to take
you know some shape
and your training data is going to
decide what the shape of this is
right so that's that's that's you know
you got to think of it this way where
the um
this would probably again be
some some kind of ah
up upward bending but the x-axis
over here is data the x-axis over here
is mu and sigma
so this is probability and this
is likelihood so if you are given
a different collection of training data
your likelihood function is going to
take a different shape be located
somewhere else it may take a diff you
know
it may look very different and this may
not even integrate over to
one you know the area under this or the
volume under this
under the likelihood function but for a
probability density function
the the parameters will decide the shape
and the volume under under this function
will always integrate to one
so um yeah it's it's it's
the the uh the analogy of taking a slice
it doesn't quite hold um you know
they're just two different
you think of them as two different
functions
what is the best
exactly so uh the the the problem
that we're going to attack with the
likelihood function is given the
training data that we have
we want to choose some mu and sigma that
maximizes the likelihood the most
right and that's that's that that's
basically
uh uh like the big picture of what we do
in statistics you're given a data that
data is going to
you know implicitly define some kind of
a likelihood function and now we want to
find
the parameters that make the given data
you know most probable
it's it's it's i'm not intentionally not
going to go into the the
details of you know will a maximum
always exist or not
uh but this is the intention intuition
you want to have there are technical
conditions that
make a maximum exist uh and things like
that but you know that's beyond the
scope
you know for most of our problems you
know you know
this this is the intuition that you want
to have you know the the
um the likelihood is a function defined
over the parameter space
and the shape of the function is going
to be different
according to the data that we have and
the probability you know which is which
is like the other way it's defined over
the observations of the data
and different parameters is going to
give you you know different probability
density functions
there was another question yes
we again hold that thought we're going
to if we're going to uh uh
um talk about what we you know how we're
going to extend this into machine
learning but this is you know
gen uh you know classical statistics
what's likelihood what's probability
right
yes question
yes yes so uh the question was when we
you know based on you know in based on
the
uh training data that we are given we
can estimate a mu and sigma and that mu
and sigma
is going to define some probability
distribution and that's the
and using this distribution is what
we're going to use for making
predictions over future data
that's that's that's the uh rough idea
right so that's that's ah maximum
likelihood
um and
the procedure you know that we're going
to follow is
in some kind of i know an abstract like
you know in an abstract way
if l theta given
x is the likelihood function
take some form where x is uh um
so suppose we are given some training
data and it you know
we make an assumption that it belongs to
some distribution for example the
gaussian
right the likelihood is going to take
some form and that's going to be of the
form of sum
now product of i equals 1 to n
you know l of theta
x i i'm intentionally not expanding out
what
l is it could be a gaussian like that
and the maximum likelihood
procedure basically tells us that theta
hat
so in general we use the the notation
that we're going to use is we're going
to put a hat over things that are
estimated
right things that are given to us like
training data or
you know we just use them as variables
but things that we estimate as the
output of some some estimation process
we're going to put a hat over it right
and theta hat
and i am going to use the subscript mle
to say that we use the maximum
likelihood procedure to estimate this
is going to be arg max
of theta r
of i equals one to n
the likelihood of theta for each x i
right so think of you know for example
in case of the gaussian
you can think of this expression coming
over
coming in over here right and further
i'm going to make this claim and this is
always going to be the same as
r max of log
of product of i equals 1 to n
l theta
what did i do here there was this
this function the likelihood function
defined over all your training examples
and i make a claim here that instead of
maximizing this the product of these
i am going to maximize the log of the
product of these
right and why is this true
log is a monotonically increasing
function
and if we want to the the
the theta that we obtain with this will
always be the theta will always be the
same as the theta that we obtain with
this
because it's a monotonically increasing
function yes
okay let's keep that question for for uh
uh uh you know i'm gonna answer that
after that let's
uh just because i'm running short of
time i want to you know
cover a few more things uh but in
general we're going to assume some form
some probability density and just going
to work with that
right now um here the
um so
we replace the uh the thing that we want
to uh
maximize with with the log of of the
same thing
it's important to note that here we are
calculating the arg max
you know if you were just calculating
the max then of course these two are
different
but here we are calculating the arg max
so the
the theta that maximizes this will also
be the same theta that maximizes the log
of this
right because we are doing the arg max
and this can now be written as
arg max of theta
sum of i equals 1 to n
small l of theta
x i where
l of theta is equal to
log of that
right so the log of a product of a few
terms is the sum of the log of the
individual terms
right and ah the the
and we replace the the function l with
the log of itself
now um what would happen if l were to be
a gaussian
if if if we assume that our training
data x is coming from a multivariate
gaussian
we would then plug in so
so far it's a standard template no
matter what problem that we have
you know this is the recipe that we're
going to follow for maximum likelihood
estimation
and to take this further
we now have to get into the functional
form of what the
likelihood function actually is for that
problem
right and in this case for gaussian
it's going to be arg max
of now so far we were
just talking about theta in in general
but now we are going to talk about the
parameters of the gaussian
here we were you know by theta we were
just mentioning the parameters of
whatever distribution that we are going
to use
in an abstract way and
sum over i equals 1 to n
log of this whole thing
1 over 2 pi to the
d by 2. this is going to look
a little big but it's going to simplify
i promise
to exponent of
minus half x minus mu
transpose sigma inverse x minus one
right so
can we simplify this further yes we can
so there is an exponent and there is a
log right so
the exponent and log cancel out and it's
the log of the product of two terms
you know and that can be broken down
into the sum of the logs of the
individual terms right
and here i'm going to use this as mu hat
comma sigma hat and this
is um
our max mu
sigma and sum over i equals 1 to
n so i'm going to break this down into
three parts
right 1 over 2 pi to the d by 2 and the
log of that
is going to be some constant it is some
constant there are no variables there
so i am just going to write that as some
constant k
right plus
log or half log of the determinant
of sigma right
is it plus half or minus half sorry
minus half plus log of the exponent
they're going to cancel and there's a
minus
minus half x minus
mu transpose
sigma inverse x minus mu
right and now
this is some function this whole thing
is some function
of mu and sigma we are going to think of
x as
as given this should be x i
now how do we do the arg max
calculus right take the take the
derivative set the derivative equal to 0
and solve for mu and sigma
right and we have time to do this today
yeah we have some time so
here here um and this is where
the things we reviewed over the last
couple of days are gonna you know uh
come in handy
we saw how to take the derivative of
quadratic forms
we saw how to take the derivative of a
log of a determinant of a matrix
right and those things are going to be
used
right away over here
was the question again
so this is the the summation applies for
the whole thing the summation is for
all the terms in there
so i am going to write it out here so we
need to maximize this with respect to
two variables
mu and sigma jointly so we are going to
take
partial derivatives so let us lets solve
it separately so this is for mu
and this is for sigma right
and so the derivative with respect to
mu
of summation i equals 1 to
n k times
minus half log
sigma minus half
x i minus mu
transpose sigma inverse
right and when we take the derivative
uh and this is going to be sum over i
equals 1 to n
derivative of k with respect to mu is 0
derivative of
log determinant of this with respect to
mu is 0
and all what we are left with is the
derivative with respect to the quadratic
form
right and so the
we saw that the derivative of x with
respect to
uh x transpose ax
is equal to 2 ax
if it's symmetric and sigma is symmetric
it's a covariance matrix
so covariance matrices are always
symmetric right
and there's a half and there's um and
the half is going to cancel with the two
right and this will give us ah minus
x i minus mu
so let me expand this out to ah
in case it causes any confusion
we're going to expand this out so that
will give us
so minus half is a common is common for
everything
x i transpose sigma inverse
x i so this is just the distributive
property of
multiplication you take every every pair
and write it out
ah minus
x i transpose sigma inverse
mu and the other way minus
mu transpose sigma inverse
x i plus mu
transpose sigma inverse mu
is it clear how we went from this step
to this step
it's just the you know the distribution
distributive property of multiplication
um and now we still want to take with
respect to mu
right and this is equal to some over i
equals 1 to n
minus half
right this has no mu in it so this is
just going to
be 0. this and this are the same thing
because it's a scalar
and you can take the transpose of each
other right
so i'm going to write this as let me
still written
to mu um
this is going to be
sigma inverse
and the transpose of that is is the same
x i transpose
mu minus 2 of that
plus mu transpose sigma inverse mu
right and now take the derivative in
it's going to be
i equals 1 to n minus half
and the 2 cancel out and
this will be this will be
with respect to mu so this is just sigma
inverse
x i and this is the quadratic form
and that's going to come with the 2 the
2 and the 2 cancel
there's going to be a minus 2
or the 2 cancels sorry
sigma inverse mu
right and then we set it equal to 0
and solve for mu and this will basically
give us
that n times because it is a summation
over
n n times sigma inverse mu equals
summation i equals 1 to n
sigma inverse x
i and sigma inverse you can you can ah
take it out and
i'm going to continue it here and that
that will give us basically
sigma inverse mu is equal to
sigma inverse 1 over
n i equals 1 to n
x i right and multiply with sigma on
both sides you get mu
equals one over n i equals one to n
x i
right so mu is just the average of the
x's
that are given to us it's it's it's a
it's a it looks pretty tedious
it's something you want to you know go
back home and
and re-derive it on your own just to
make sure you're comfortable with it
and this is going to be probably the
last time you're going to do such
detailed
derivations on board right um
going forward you know i'm just going to
defer it to you to verify the
derivations
but this is the sense
now what about sigma
we want to estimate the parameter
sigma but we see here that we have a
sigma inverse
right how do you take you know that
makes it a little complex
well so sigma inverse is not the same as
1 by sigma because sigma is a matrix
right what is 1 over a matrix there's no
such thing as 1 over a matrix
right you have a matrix inverse which is
another matrix
right right so ah now we for for doing
it with respect to sigma
we are going to use a change of variable
trick which means
we are going to consider a variable s
which is equal to sigma inverse and make
the observation that
the gradient of some function
l with respect to s is equal to 0
if and only if gradient of respect to
sigma inverse
of l equals 0
does it make sense
right and then we are going to solve it
for x solve for s
and once we get the s we are going to
invert it and the inverse of that is
going to be the sigma that we want
right this is a a pretty standard
classical
change of variable trick that you do
with calculus
right so
this thing over here so now we're going
to take the derivative with respect to s
i equals 1 to n half
log there is a minus and so this will
make it
to s and minus half
x minus mu transpose
s x minus mu is going to be
x i x i
right and
the derivative of a log determinant with
respect to the matrix is
s inverse s inverse it's not 1 by s 1
over s it is s inverse
and we're going to
sum over n such things so that is going
to be
n times s inverse
and there's a half outside
minus
what's the what's the
equation with respect to a of x
transpose a x
so we saw what it is with respect to x
what is it with respect to a
i'm going to leave it as an exercise and
you will have to verify
that this is just x x transpose
okay yes question
so i took a half that's outside is there
another negative that's probably another
negative
oh yeah so that's where the negative
comes in so the the the uh
log so log of 1 over something becomes
the negative of the log of something
right so that's where the the the
negative got cancelled out
i'm sorry
i mean there is one um
but this should be yeah that makes sense
sorry
and minus um sum
i equals 1 to n x
i minus mu
x i minus mu transpose
which means s and and you set this
equal to 0 the half cancels and you get
s inverse equals 1 over n
i equals 1 to n x i
minus mu x i
minus mu transpose
right and s inverse is equal to
sigma right so
sigma is 1 over n
x i minus mu x i minus mu transpose and
this
you know its its similar to expectation
of
x minus expectation of
x square right you can kind of
see the similar exactly right and this
that's that's your covariance matrix
this question
there's a minus that got that absorbed
the one over s
as determined yeah
right so anyway so if you have questions
about this you know uh come up the stage
after the lecture
but uh this is this is you know this
gives you a flavor of how to do maximum
likelihood estimation
right and the the you know um
you're expected to be comfortable to do
this kind of matrix calculus
to derive maximum likelihood estimates
right and and we're going to be doing a
whole lot of such
matrix calculus you know throughout the
course for different kinds of models
and this is just a simple model a
multivariate gaussian
where uh you know where this gets used
now
what are we going to be uh doing for
linear regression
i don't think we have time for linear
regression but maybe you know just give
you a flavor of what
linear regression is about so for linear
regression
it's a supervised learning problem and a
supervised learning problem
is a problem in which we want to learn
relations between
x and y so we're going to be given
training sets in the in the form of x
i y i pairs
right you're going to be given pairs of
x i y i where x i is
some kind of a vector a d dimensional
vector
and we are going to be given n such
pairs
right so this this terminology means
this is it's it's a it's a pair of x
um um x i and y i and you have you know
i from 1 to n
you have n such pairs right that's the
terminology we use over here
and y is going to be in r
and we want to learn a function right
we're going to call that function as
h of x and we want h of x
to output y right and
this h is going to be parameterized by
some theta
and in this case theta was mu and and
sigma
over here theta is going to be something
else ah that we we're going to be see
and from the given training data set we
want to learn
the function h theta of x which means
you are given a training set
right from this training set you're
going to construct
h theta so this is called the learning
process
the learning algorithm
right this was x y pairs
and the output of the learning process
is an algorithm
right so the h data is the output of of
the learning algorithm itself
and into h theta we're going to feed new
x
let's call it x star unseen axis and
it's supposed to output y's for the
unseen axis right this is like
the the the macro setting of regression
problems or supervised learning problems
right and in the next lecture we're
going to
uh see a couple of algorithms for
for uh learning linear relationships
between x and y and that's going to be
linear regression